foreign
[Music]
okay E4 let's play
yeah let's play E5 which is what we have
been playing the last couple of games
which is
sort of the premise of the speedrun that
we're playing classical openings
all right four nights not my favorite
opening to play against but
it is what it is
oh the board is messed up apology
apologies there we go
okay so we have a Four Knights and
Knight takes C5 the Halloween Gambit
actually not such a bad line and it's it
doesn't get enough coverage in books and
stuff you have to know how to play
against it and I haven't reviewed in a
very long time but we are going to play
A variation of it that allows us to
avoid much of the theory so we accept
the Halloween Gambit
and white plays D4 now if we analyze
with an engine and I honestly forgot
what the best line is I think the best
line according to the engine is to keep
the extra piece how do you keep the
extra piece you drop the Knight back to
C6 white pushes E5 and then you tuck the
other Knight away to its initial Square
G8 and according to Modern Theory white
does not have enough compensation for
the sacrifice Knight but I will be
honest I'm totally out of my league in
this line and my guess is that our
opponent has analyzed it so we are going
to dodge the theorem we're going to
dodge the most dangerous parts of the
Lion
uh yeah maybe Knight G6 is the line
maybe Knight G6 actually Knight G6 is
the move that I want to play but not
because we're going to keep the Knight
we're actually going to sacrifice the
Knight back and that's the good thing
about facing these types of gambits if
you're not sure what to do remember it
you can always give the piece back up
and what you can gain in return is a
bunch of developments so we don't have
to move the Knight on F6 at all we can
simply continue as though nothing is the
matter we played Bishop before
developing our Bishop to a good Square
then we play Queen take step six and I
have a hard time believing the black
could possibly be worse in this position
and people are confirming that Knight 26
is indeed the line and remember that
psychologically Gambit players hate
of line where you sack the piece back
and you take a lot of the life out of
the position
Queenie to check okay that's a very
risky move uh because one thing that we
could do here is move our King to d8 in
order to make space for The Rook to move
into E8 but we've been playing this in a
very kind of positional style so the the
Soviet Schoolboy move would be Queen E6
or queen E7 but Queen E6 I like a lot
because then we're gonna play Queen E6
because
efy trades we can take toward the center
with our F Pawn and as a result of that
we can open up the f file so that when
we Castle later on we'll put pressure on
the F2 Pawn so we're going to play this
in a very solid style also after Queen
takes C6 we can take with the d-pawn and
try to do the same thing to the D4 Pawn
Bishop D2
all right so classic standoff between
the queens and in such situations you
want to avoid being the one to release
the tension and to help your opponent
develop we don't want to take on E2 that
would be a pretty senseless move it
would simply help white develop his
Bishop instead we want to continue
developing we want a castle
and this okay Queen takes C6 it's hard
to say what we should take with
originally I wanted to take with the F
Pawn but the problem with taking with
the F Pawn is that our Bishop on CD is
like hey what the heck like how am I
getting out when you've got these pawns
on D7 and E6 so again in the interest of
playing as solid as possible let's
actually take with the d-pawn which
opens up the D file number one number
two it is now much easier to develop the
light squared Bishop to D7 give the
bishop a little bit of air the position
is completely equal here how are we
going to win this we're gonna win this
by being patient and first we're going
to win this by developing our pieces so
Bishop D7 comes next A3
and we could trade on C3
we could trade on C3 I think that's a
very sensible decision in fact I think
it's a very interesting decision to
trade here most people wouldn't do it
most people would not take on C3
but I'm going to prove to you guys that
this has a lot of Venom leaving white
without a knight in this type of
position let's play Bishop C6 getting
the bishop to the long diagonal is a
line that is a lot of Venom because my
point is that the bishop on C3 is a very
bad piece we are going to be basically
launching a campaign against the bishop
on C3 and our overall plan is going to
be to pile up on the D4 Pawn which seems
like one of the most well-defended
bastions and blacks in White's position
but we're gonna double our Rooks and
then we're gonna try to get the Knight
to F5 and before you know it that pawn
on D4 let's start doubling Rooks is
going to become a Sitting Duck if white
does not address it we're going to start
playing a little bit faster here because
our opponent is playing very confidently
and very quickly let's start doubling
our Rooks the position I would say is
still equal and like I said in the
previous Speed Run video or two videos
ago
knowing how to outplay good players from
these types of positions is an
incredibly important skill
Bishop H3 okay I don't see what this
threatens so I think we can continue
with our plan Rook 88 I okay Rook h e
one
all right so now it's time for us to
take care of this Knight this Knight is
going to head back toward E7
and then either to D5 into the center or
to F5 if the sir if the opportunity
presents itself
if the opportunity presents itself I see
a little trap
okay wait but Knight D5 maybe runs into
F5
Knight T5 maybe runs into F5
so let me think about this for a second
you know what would be a good move in
this position
you know what what I think would be a
very good move is H5 in order to prevent
white from playing G4 we're trying to
make it impossible for white to push F5
so we're playing along the light Square
so we're going to set up a light Square
blockade which may seem like a very
passive approach but we're trying to
keep White's pawns as immobile as
possible so now we go G6 we make it very
hard for white to push his spawns on the
king's side notice also that Rook takes
E6 is nothing to fear because we simply
take back and at the end white loses the
light skirt Bishop so our Pawn structure
is incredibly watertight
we're we're doing fine here I mean our
opponent is playing very well he's not
he's not bending just yet but we're
gonna try to keep applying pressure and
applying pressure and eventually I think
White's gonna give out
so what am I thinking about in this
position well what I'm thinking about is
that how nice would it be if our Knight
had the C6 Square it would be very nice
if our Knight had a C6 card because it
would apply even more pressure on the D4
Pawn a lot of people would go Knight D5
here but that's a bit of a dead end I
would prefer for the Knight to move into
C6 how can we do that well we can play
Bishop F3 but that has a drawback it
allows Rook D3 with Tempo I don't want
to allow a Tempo instead we're going to
build a square for the bishop we're
going to play B6 and we're going to drop
the bishop back to B7 in order to be
able to play Knight C6 and the other
benefit of this is that we can now push
our C Pawn up to C5 if necessary
okay ooh this is almost a blunder
but somehow white survives after Knight
C6 rookie 4.
man
very fortunate there if we play C5 white
as D5
okay let's go Knight C6 anyway
of course Knight A5 is a move but the
problem is rookie 4 Knight A5 flight is
rookie three very very fortunate for the
white has these these moves yeah rookie
4 we might want to repeat moves and then
get our Knight to F5 maybe that's a
better approach
yeah he finds the move
another another problem is that D5 could
be very unpleasant here
D5 could be very unpleasant here
okay let's go Rook D6
let's play Rook D6
yeah maybe what I did with H5 G6 was a
mistake because it has of course we can
the dark square is quite quite
extensively so I underestimated that
we're gonna have to spin our way out of
that
yeah I'm quite concerned about D5 here
which I honestly totally forgot about
just like totally forgot the D5 is an
idea
yeah we have to be very careful not to
get mated there
but we have resources okay wow
yeah this guy is this guy is very strong
Knight A5 was my initial idea but
okay let's do let's do it let's play
Knight A5
yeah very very strong player
let's play Knight A5
the problem is that there's this rookie
eight idea so we can never leave The
Rook
we have to keep one regarding the
seventh rank at all times or the eighth
rank at all times
which really limits our options Bishop
F6 okay
so if we play Knight takes B3 check wait
a minute that that looks like a mistake
but I we need to calculate here so
if we play e takes D5 Bishop takes d8
D takes E4
Rook takes D6 C takes D6 we are upon up
I think black is better there
so that's one option we can play Ed
if we play Knight takes B3 check the
king moves to B2
we play Knight C5 Bishop takes the 894
and white takes on C7
at the end of the line so we have to
play e takes D5 I'll show these lines
after the game but we're running very
low on time here so I'm gonna start
playing quite fast
okay do you take C4
Rook takes D6 CD
the good thing about this is that Knight
on A5 which we positioned there is a
monster piece it's a monster piece
because it's attacking B3 and it's
giving what does it give us it gives us
a Tempo what can we use this Tempo to do
well we can use this Tempo to do a bunch
of different things we can push E3
although we run the risk of losing that
pawn
the other thing we can do is bring our
King closer to f8 we can also play the
move F5 which I really like what F5 does
is it solidifies it solidifies the
entire Pawn chain but the drawback of F5
is that white has Bishop C7 attacking D6
and if we play D5 there white has the
crazy move C5
using the undefended nature of the
Knight so
we actually are going to go
the problem with King f8 is that he's
got Bishop F6 but I think this is better
than nothing
incredible tactics for white oh yeah wow
okay so let's go
let me think about this I'm I'm debating
between King Y8 and EFA and D5
cooking here let's bring the king a
little bit closer
and if King if King C3 will go D5
yeah here we'll go D5
no he's totally legit it's just a very
strong player
not as I've said not every single game
is going to be equally smooth sometimes
I'm going to make mistakes
and I'm gonna have to get out of them
obviously black is playing for a win
here we're up a pawn but White's Bishops
are incredibly strong and he's up a lot
of time so this is going to be a big
challenge to win let's go back to C6
now I'm concerned about B5
okay for probably even better
so e3b5
maybe a five but no he then goes B5
now let's go E3 let's see what happens
let's play E3
because if black plays if white plays B5
the one positive of inducing that move
is that it fixes the pawns on a light
Square so that if the king moves away we
can play Bishop B3
it's not all bad here
I wouldn't say I'm in trouble here I
think the position is probably equal
but it's going to be very hard to win
this with black I don't think black is
worse we have an extra passed Pawn on E3
for goodness sake
but yeah
let's go 97.
move the Knight away and here's the
point if White NOW plays King D4 or King
D3 we have the move Bishop to B3 what
I'm worried about is A5 and that is a
super high level move A5 in order to to
shatter Black's Queen Side Pawn
structure using the strength of the
Bishops B takes A5 Bishop D4
and the A7 Pawn is in trouble Bishop E5
also very strong going for B8
okay I think it's time for E2 and Bishop
B3
let's do it
bailout
and we can try Bishop C4 which is a very
ambitious move let me calculate Bishop
C4 Bishop B8 Knight D5
also interesting by the way
if we play Bishop B3
white plays Bishop B8
we take y takes
there's no way we're winning the game if
that happens
but I don't see an alternative let's do
it
yeah very well played my opponent I have
to say let's try Knight T5
there are still some tricks
there are still some tricks
but the problem is there's Bishop G2 wow
one more trick that I have up my sleeve
and now Bishop B6 is what I'm hoping for
it's amazing I mean he plays perfectly
up until the very last and then wonders
of Peace but wait this is far from over
I have to focus guys and what people
watching on YouTube I apologize in
advance for the sparse
explanations here but I I really need to
focus here to try to win this
this is far from Easy even though we're
up a piece
it's one of those positions as you
understand where
the pawn on B5 is tying down or nine and
a half 46 seconds so
yeah and he continues to play incredibly
well here
yeah but H3 is another mistake because
we suddenly dropped back to E7 attacking
the bishop
attacking the bishop and now we're going
to take on H3 in the next move and then
we're going to be up a full piece but I
have no time so this is going to be a
tall order
six
it should be a bishop F5
okay we complete five anyway
maybe not the best way I'm playing this
but okay Knight F6 we want to go Knight
E4
let's go here
stop the pawn
now we go 94 anyway the point is B7 we
can stop it with King C7
and now we're going to take G3
and we're going to Simply push h4h3h2
and we win wow that was probably the
closest speedrun game we've had thus far
outside of course of my games against
cheaters
because this guy's very clearly legit
just like an amazingly played game and
the thing that I'll begin with
the thing that and I'm definitely not
proud of my level of play that was a
couple of misjudgments and a couple of
like flat out misses I'm just gonna flat
out say that my level of play was not
super high this game which also makes it
instructive because I'll be able to
explain like what exactly I missed in my
defense it is late I'm running out of
gas but I'll do my best to to shed some
light on what happened as we analyze so
first of all I don't think I have ever
faced the Halloween Gambit
so I never studied it you know I'm an E5
player but I've never studied this
properly
and I was afraid to play Knight G8
because there is a good amount of theory
here I don't know what White's main move
is and the engine gives minus 1.5 but I
know that
looks like Bishop C4 is the line
and now apparently you're supposed to
sacrifice one of the pawns back
why are you supposed to do that in order
to open up the center and help yourself
develop your pieces more effectively so
it looks like yeah D5 is a very common
type of idea in such positions to sack
one of the pawns and after Bishop takes
D5 two games continued C6 Bishop B3
Bishop B4 and I think it's it's
pretty obvious
that in this position white has
insufficient compensation for the two
for the piece white has two pawns but
notice that we have control over all the
light squares so even if white plays F4
by the way the engine recommends H5
which is similar to what we did in the
game then we put the bishop on F5 and
you have total dominance over all the
light squares uh on the king side so
it's impossible for white to push F5
but we decided to give the piece back
which I think is the totally valid
approach the engine doesn't love this
what's interesting I think is that if
you are giving the piece back
after Knight C6 E5
yeah I don't know if the way that we did
it was the best way to give the piece
back maybe not but anyways Queen takes
F6 and queen E2 is actually I think in
retrospect a very strong move because if
white doesn't play Queen E2 then we get
to Castle and we get to play D5 and the
position is dead equal for example if
white plays Bishop C4 then I was
planning a very strong move in this
position a strong positional move C6
C6 castles D5
everything is groovy rookie one Bishop
E6 were fully developed we're happy
black is probably even better in this
position
what's the point in controlling light
dark source and games well
okay Square control is inherently good
and I'll have videos eventually on
Square control and what that means but
if you look at this concrete position
don't overthink it the point of
controlling F5 is to prevent white from
playing F5 and rolling you off the board
and the point of controlling G4 is to
prevent white from playing G4 which
ultimately prepares F5 which rolls you
off the board so controlling a complex
of squares in a positional sense greatly
limits your opponent's ability to
operate on those squares and when I say
the word operate what I mean is to use
pawns to advance pawns to those squares
or to use pieces it's like buying a
hotel in Monopoly it's like every time
you land on it you get charged
it's it's your house
when you can operate on these squares as
you see fit
okay so Queen E2 check was the first
thing that I sort of underestimated okay
Queen E6 I think Queen E6 is normal and
Bishop D2
castles
and queen takes E6 I think our opponent
chose a very appropriate moment to trade
Queens
and a lot of people don't understand is
they think every time I play a 2100 I'm
gonna blow them off the board okay that
that's not how things work even in IRL
if you were watching my US Open games
which was my last OTB tournament in
round two I faced the 2100. I was worse
on move 40. like the idea that top
players are going to roll
serious amateur you can say serious
amateurs or Club players off the board
is absurd there are going to be certain
games which take on certain paths where
the Queens can be traded early and when
the Queens are traded early the margin
of error widens if you have a very solid
end game you're gonna have three or four
moves on every position that keeps the
approximate evaluation it's very hard
even for a GM to win such games which is
why you will occasionally see a GM
drawing a 21 or 2200 right that's not
impossible and some people think it's
impossible
so queenies and this is a great example
of that right we get a totally equal end
game or even an endgame or white is a
tiny bit better
why does Super solid the structure is
symmetrical and all of those things make
this game a lot harder to win
okay
now I was really hoping that Whitewood
Castle queenside here does anybody see
why this is a mistake why would it have
been a mistake
for YT Castle queenside
yeah Bishop takes C3 very good
and if Queen takes E6 Intermezzo you win
a piece and if Bishop takes E3 then
Queen takes A2 and you win a very
important Pawn on A2
so I was hoping for that but instead
white plays Queen takes E6 so we played
de6 to open up the bishop castles Queen
side Bishop D7 A3 this is very normal
okay the decision to take on C3
was not totally disapproved up by the
engine
it's a questionable one in a classical
game I would have dropped the bishop
back to E7 and I wanted to unbalance the
position right one of the advice that
piece of advice you're given is a high
rated player is to introduce imbalances
into the position right the more
imbalances the you know the more
complicated the position
and so that's why I decided to play
Bishop takes C3 my goal essentially was
to play against the dark squared Bishop
I thought that the dark squared Bishop
is a very bad piece and my long-term
plan here was to pile up on the D4 Pawn
which is a very long-term plan like
you're nowhere near doing that just yet
okay so Rogue G1 Rook G1 is a pretty
weird move I don't think it's the best
move I think the best move would have
been to play F3 and close the bishop
down and if I had to choose the side
here I would probably prefer White
so rochi one is a little bit a little
bit idle though I don't think it's a
terrible Maverick fd8
why is the bishop a bad piece well it's
bad because it's
I mean it's surrounded by pawns it has
no prospects it's just staring at at its
own weakness right
how do you decide keeping queens or
trading them as bad well there's no
commute I mean it's obvious that there's
no there's no algorithm that yields an
answer in every position
but in this particular instance I wasn't
the one who decided to keep the Queens
on the board why was the one who traded
and the reason why traded I think is
because white can't otherwise Castle
queenside so here it's a very
concrete reasoning it's it's not like up
in the air it's like white can't
continue developing unless the Queens
are off the board
so
but but it's a hard question it's a very
hard question and these general
questions like how do you know when to
keep Queens on the board even GMS find
them to be very difficult
okay so G3
now we start doubling our Rooks Bishop
H3 I thought was a very interesting move
Rook 88 Rook he1 97 we start guiding our
Knight toward D5 or potentially towards
C6 as in the game
F4 and here I think I made maybe not a
very serious mistake I think H5 is fine
no the engine actually likes what I did
this is interesting I wonder where the
mistake was after B3
B6 is still good
okay I think I know where the mistake
was
this is still fine
oh actually no I like basically playing
all the top moves which is really really
funny all of these are top moves even
Rook D6 black is better here
see five Knight A5 also top move
and so is he D so I was just wrong
I think I think I I just underestimated
my play both of us were playing pretty
high level chess here and I I am
parroting the engine but I was like
really curious to see if I had made any
serious mistakes I will say that I'm
still not in love with the way that I
played
and what I probably would do if I had a
do-over is a move that a lot of you
would probably find very strange I would
play Knight F5 now it's a logical move
it attacks D4
but it allows a trade of Bishops and
you're taught that opposite colored
Bishops equals draw opposite colored
Bishops does not equal draw if there are
Rooks on the board in addition why is
black better here why does black hold
all the winning chances in this position
it has to do with the E4 Square you have
a monster Square for the for the light
squared Bishop
a monster Square you have pressure on D4
you have the ability to bring the king
out into the center and this is like a
super Pleasant position black can
torture white for ages here and one way
that you can torture white let's just
let's make a couple of random moves
white is to open up a second front right
you can basically say Okay white is
really passive but as long as the
position remains relatively closed I'm
not going to be able to exploit that so
C5 is a very dangerous option if the
king loses contact with the Rook if it
doesn't you can go on the other side you
can play H5 you see GMS playing these
types of moves very often all you're
trying to do is open up another file
you're trying to open the H file the
rule is when you're more active you
generally want the position to be open
right your opponent is less prepared for
that than H4
right then Rock Hade and then you still
not only start infiltrating down the
h-bell nothing happens fast here
if white plays H4 then guess what you
have induced another weakness how do we
exploit that weakness well how about
Rook h8 Rook H6 and Rook G6 so patiently
applying pressure
this is probably what I would have
chosen
if I had a do-over
what about B65 yeah as I just indicated
that is also a viable plan
so we decided to play along the light
squares H5 and G6
controlling all of these key squares and
preventing white from pushing his pawns
forward and shattering our King side
and you might say well I don't get it
why is H5 necessary
well if we would have played B6
immediately as I had planned to
initially I was very worried about the
prospect of white pushing G4 and then
shoving F5 through after efgf look at
how the position opens up I mean F6 is a
threat Bishop B4 this has already become
a very nasty position
so
you know all we're trying to do is
prevent white from achieving Mobility
with his pawns and keeping the king side
closed until we are ready to reopen it
does that make sense playing on the
light squares
okay so G6 B3 and now the second stage
of our plan which is to vacate the C6
Square for our Knight why do we do that
in order to attack White's weakness the
D4 upon which has been our plan all
along
now white finds a very powerful counter
resource Bishop B2 Bishop B7
C4 and at this point I suddenly realized
that white has this threat of
transforming his weakness into a
strength which is one of the beautiful
things about Chess the pod on D4 has
been a major weakness for white all
throughout the end game and yet white
threatens to push D5 that pawn becomes
White's greatest strength Knight C6 Rook
E4 unfortunately we don't have any
discoveries all we can do is play Rook
D6 in order to unpin the rook and take
the sting out of the move D5
all right I briefly considered the move
F5 unfortunately it doesn't work because
if after Rook takes E6 the pod on G6 is
hanging
that doesn't work Rook D6 I think makes
perfect sense D5 and Knight A5 we had to
be very accurate here
there's a very important line here
after after B4 we play e takes D5 white
plays C takes D5 and we have Bishop
takes D5
white plays Rook takes D5 and B takes A5
and says hey I have got two Bishops for
The Rook which is typically overwhelming
the line continues check
and in this sorry King B3 white
threatens Checkmate in two moves can you
find a way to prevent mate while also
creating a threat how do you keep the
tempo going here
F5 Bingo very nice F5 creating some Luft
and if white plays rookie six Rook P1
and the bishop on B2 is lost I didn't
see this entire line I just calculated
up until F5 and I had a feeling that
black is in control of the game
so this is a very important line
obviously de6 does not work because you
drop both of the Rooks with check and so
Bishop F6 is a very sensible move
counter attacking The Rook but now e
takes D5 comes to the rescue this is a
very important move in fact without e
takes D5 I think black would be much
worse the other line that I was
calculating is Knight takes B3 check
King C2 and Knight C5
counter-attacking white truck but
unfortunately after Bishop takes the 894
white has Bishop takes C7
and now the d-pawn advances to D6
most players would calculate that whole
line in a classical game this is not
that hard because it's incredibly forced
SNL s oh why do we need to move the
Knight well that's a great question we
actually don't need to move tonight but
it's like can you find something better
to do it's not that we have to move the
Knight it's that I wanted to move
tonight I wanted to move the Knight
because I wanted to attack B3 and I
wanted to attack D5 it isn't because we
have to move it it just so happens that
the best move is with the Knight it's
not because the Knight is threatened
because it's not threatened D1 Falls
with check that's a great observation
okay uh you were proposing Bishop C8
yeah but here white can play Rook d de1
here where I can play Rook D1
and already it's too late to capture
because you get checkmated
right so it's now or never in terms of
attacking White's weaknesses
okay
F5 Rook takes C6 or oh no you want to go
F5 here
okay
I'll move my Rook back I I don't think
this is a very good line though
I'll move my Rook back
I guess you could play e takes D5 here
but I can play Bishop G2 in this
position
and just look at all the pressure that
white has built and developed on Black's
position this is this is no good so I
think Knight A5 is best Ed d e and we
get into this end game which I think
should be a draw with best play
it's what's interesting is after King C2
the engine calls King f8 a mistake
according to the engine the only chance
at a big Advantage was the immediate E3
I saw this move but I just didn't have
the guts to play it I was worried that I
would end up losing that pawn
why what is the point of pushing you
through well the point is to promote a
pawn
the secondary point is that should the
white King stop the pawn
the B3 Pawn Falls and with the B3 Pawn
follows the overall Integrity of White's
Queen Side Pawn structure
does that make sense
so after King takes C3 we can drop the
Knight back to A5 and we can start
harassing the C4 Pawn black has pretty
good winning chances here we're just up
a full Pawn I mean we're up a healthy
Pawn
and King D4 is impossible because of the
fork so white has to play the
sub-optimal move King D3 which runs into
Bishop A6 and we win the second Pawn
so E3 would have been a lot more bold
and a lot more rewarding than the timid
King f8 which allows white to put the
bishop on F6 and you know this is just a
very annoying move it's like an elephant
sitting on us
the other thing that I was very close to
doing is playing F5
how natural is this move you're creating
a pawn chain the problem with this move
is why it has this resource Bishop C7
attacking D6 D5 and C5
and you can't take because you drop the
Knight
and I had no idea how to evaluate this
position this is such a wild position
both sides have sets of connected
passers I didn't want to risk losing the
game so this to me was a little bit too
brazen
so in any case Bishop F6 we bring our
King to E8 King C3 and D5 and honestly I
think of course this game should end in
a draw after Knight C6 because white has
enough activity to compensate for the
extra pawn and I think our opponent
played excellently at first B5 all of
this was perfectly done Bishop E5
E2 King D4 and Bishop P3 of course black
is the one playing for a win black is
the one in the driver's seat but I think
our opponent was doing a phenomenal job
of making the draw all the way up until
up until this moment of course all white
had to do to secure the draw was to take
the pawn on E2 rather than taking the
pawn on B6 King takes E2 Knight C4 King
D3 and actually black is the one who has
to bail out here Knight A5 Bishop B6
Knight C6 and we have a simple dead draw
so there were a couple of inaccuracies
along the way that I skipped if we're
analyzing with an engine it appears that
in this position the most accurate move
was a slightly strange move F5
I guess putting more pressure on the
king's side it doesn't really matter
what does matter is that here after b597
Bishop B5
a big Advantage was yielded by the move
Bishop to F3 so Bishop B3 was actually a
mistake I think this was a theme like I
I underestimated the value of this
passer black white plays Bishop B8 and
now here's this idea Knight C5 and if
Bishop takes A7 let's see if anybody can
spot the brilliant winning move there is
a brilliant winning idea I saw this
hypothetically but I missed the critical
detail black to play and win not Knight
C3 because this doesn't create any
threats what is this threaten it doesn't
threaten anything the king is going to
keep in contact with you one Knight E3
is correct what does this threaten this
threatens Knight C2 and E1 Queen William
I said no problem Bishop takes B6 Knight
C2 and Bishop F2 white wins this is the
line I saw
a critical detail that I missed was that
black has Knight C4 check with a fork
with a fork
and here you can actually you don't even
have to take on B6 you can even play the
move Knight B2
threatening Knight D3 check
bishop f293 and now you take and you
take with tempo and you win a second
piece
because after Bishop C8 Knight T3 you
promote to a queen
just an incredible line Knight B2 you
don't even take the bishop although
taking the bishop is winning because
these pawns are not going anywhere look
notice how the bishop prevents the
b-pawn and the Knight well the bishop
now stops both pawns and the Knight
simply returns to C2 and you promote to
a queen what an amazing line
so let's do that again why is it
necessary to put the bishop on F3 why is
the same line not work with Bishop C4
after Bishop C4 Bishop B8 Knight T5
Bishop A7 93 should be six guess what
the C4 square is occupied by the bishop
so you have to do it from F3 for that
exact reason after Knight E3
Bishop takes P6 the C4 square is free
and available for the night just makes
you realize how deep end games are in
general like this is the level of
tactics that is commonplace in what
seems to be a pretty Placid end game
so after Bishop F3 white can survive
with King to E1
and just King F2 so you have to get the
king to the other side you're not
threatening to take the bishop but what
you're doing is you're using the r
squared Bishop to restrict the the
Knight and if black plays Knight E3
then somehow Bishop D4 survives
ah so this is the key right with the
King on D2 you don't have a move with
the King on F2 you can play Bishop C3
and the path to E1 is unobstructed
perhaps white can hold a draw here
so the engine is giving like minus one
in these types of positions
so
Bishop F3 was the move Bishop B3 is a
mistake that eases that eases White's
task and here there was another chance
to go King T8 Bishop A7 King C7 probably
a better winning chance than what I did
in the game white is able to draw by
liberating the bishop with A5 and Bishop
C5 but we still would have at least
forced Dwight to find a couple of moves
would I see that in a classical game
hard to say I would like to think that I
would if I had probably 10-15 minutes to
think I think I would see that that's
not such a long line right I I was aware
of the idea of pushing E2
but all I calculated was this line I did
see 93 but I stopped here and I didn't
realize that we could defend also from
F3 to vacate the C4 Square
so it is really a shame that our
opponent played this well and you know
at the very last moment
at the very last moment
he stumbles with Bishop takes B6
allowing the fork and this is still not
an elementary win but black wins this by
preventing whites King from entering F6
and slowly we rearrange our piece okay
H3 accelerated the inhabitable because
it just gives up another Pawn white
should not play H3 white should just
bide his time with Bishop C6 but we will
play King C5
you know we'll play Knight D7 check and
we'll kind of use our Knight to shoulder
the king out of the way eventually one
of the pawns will fall either the F the
B Pawn or the H Pawn is going to fall so
so it's a shame shame that our opponent
plundered the bishop in the end but
it was an incredibly instructive game
well played by our opponent thank you
again everybody for the subs and thank
you for hanging out I will try to stream
tomorrow
but for now
thank you all I'll see everybody later
[Music]